the kids came with me on the last tour
so i started the last tour with a
three-month-old and that was the hardest
thing that i've ever done
but by the end of it i'm like girl you
can do anything but this time they're
not coming with me
they may come out for like weekend stuff
there's different holidays they'll come
or if we're nearby i feel like we roll
through nashville a lot yeah so we'll
definitely you know get to see plenty of
them get to be mom you know plenty
that's being a good mom that's looking
out for your kids and i have to toot my
husband's horn a little bit he's got it
on lock when i'm gone i never have to
like worry that the lunches aren't
getting packed and the laundry's not
getting done and that kind of stuff like
he's got it i kind of wish they missed
me a little bit when i'm gone
that's a good that's a good thing it is
it's so nice that you can you know trust
your husband so much like that i can't
say about my dad if my mom left us with
him so that's lovely well just one
parent in general it's hard
[Music]
when you're on tour obviously staying
fit is so important when it comes to
performing and i have to tell you we're
obsessed with you and your fitness your
legs are fitness goals i just need to
know the secret
nothing complicated to be honest a lot
of basic moves a lot of basic equipment
i do have an app for that we created an
app called 52 so we do that my husband
does that a lot too we do a lot of fit
52 and i love to run i like to work on
my cardio because it means a lot when
i'm singing
lots of squats lots of lunges
nothing nothing super crazy
[Music]